all right you're done let's take a look
at the solution adding support for the
location insert looks almost identical
to adding the support for weather we
just have to select the right table name
and return the right location URI
remember at the end of the function we
can just call notify change on the
content resolver
to notify all of the registered
observers note that we must use the past
in URI and not the return URI as that
will not correctly notify our cursors of
the change since we also uncommented
test insert read provider let's run our
tests just to make sure everything is
still working well note that nothing
appears on the device screen and our
test pass we're well on our way to
building our content provider